欢迎收听古爱,我是孙孟公
本集节目由NordVPN赞助
7月了暑假正式开始
大家的旅游计划应该都已准备就绪
除了帮你规划行程
也要提醒大家NordVPN不只是VPN
而是一个全方位数位安全解决方案
只要一个APP就可以阻止钓鱼诈骗
提供反诈骗服务进行暗网监控
还能够封锁弹出是广告等
为你的数位生活打造最坚实的防护网
当然旅游时想省钱
NordVPN依然是规划行程最实用的工具
面对贵松松的机票
透过切换不同地区比价
对于想要精打细算
控制预算的人来说
一键完成切换相当实用
除了比价
使用NOR VPN
也可以大大的提升网络安全保障
在规划行程时
常常在家里咖啡厅
或是外出使用各种网络环境查资料定行程
但公共网络在安全性上较难掌握
这个时候使用NOR VPN
可以帮助加密网络连线
就算是在公共WiFi环境下
查询住宿机票
或是登录账号处理付款
也能够多一层保障
同时连线速度稳定
不太会影响实际的操作体验
如果之后人已经在国外
NordVPN也可以切换回台湾的IP
连接熟悉的网站或常用服务
使用上会更加顺畅
像我自己也会使用NordVPN
来跨区使用一些软体
或像是手游锁区可以靠它解决
而且现在NordVPN不只是支援手机平板跟电脑
也支援Smart TV和Apple Vision Pro
一个账号最多可以同时使用于10台装置
不论在家或是外出都能够灵活使用
下次要透过资讯栏的专属链接
nordvpn.com slash gooye
或在结账的时候输入优惠码 gooye
立即享有期间限定优惠
购买两年方案加送四个月
并提供30天退款保证
不满意都能够随时取消零风险尝试
红颖路比真的超屌
我现在心中是那种百感交集
因为一开始确实是蛮紧张的
虽然它不是我们肖南资本
唯一一个投资
我们后面还有很多游戏要登场
但是它是第一个
就是在我們頭後上市的遊戲
所以你說不緊張是騙人的
心中一定是百感交集
一方面是看到一個作品終於要登場了
二方面是擔心說會不會不小心有bug
還是說網友的口味可能不喜歡之類的
擔心說會不會我們的第一款作品
假設沒有獲得巨大成功的話
後面的幾款作品怎麼辦
有沒有可能大家投降下去
然後頭就沒了之類的
你說錢不見得怎麼樣
對我們來講真的是小事
就是錢賠掉也不在意
反正你看我現在股票整天在跌
那早就已經不知道跌掉幾個硝難資本了
但是心中的想法是
我覺得錢賠掉沒有關係可是這種理念然後跟對夢想的一種執著跟熱血因為我們每個參與的股東幾乎從小就是打遊戲長大
大家想看著台灣遊戲
可以順利的登場世界舞台
我就覺得
我不知道
我在心中許下非常多願望
都是希望他成功
可能是最近
就是心中想最多的事情
那所以呢
最後面看到
《紅顏露比》的登場
在記期待
同時又有一點
怕受到傷害的心情之下
把這個遊戲買下來開始玩
打過第一個BOSS
因為前面的demo已經是大家都打過第一個BOSS
所以你知道到這邊絕對是沒問題的
然後到第二個
然後到第三個
然後到老婆叫人去吃飯
你說沒空你要打電動
到晚上可能不睡覺喝咖啡在那邊尻
到早上一時鐘繼續玩
你就知道說幹重了
這真的重了
這個就是我自己本身也超級喜歡的遊戲
所以這是充滿很多的感動
就是我已經不需要去看說什麼
同時在線人數是多少
我一開始在網路上發的時候
是一千塊還是有摸到兩千
這個其實以一個
這種獨立製作遊戲來說
算是很不錯的成績
後來也很幸運的看到一些直播主
海外有一個叫什麼
Eligis是不是
然後這個直播主
他同時在線觀看了8000多
然後最後面這個影片的存檔
有10萬多人觀看
我非常期待在這個週末
會不會去引起一種
在海外的風潮
越來越多海外的直播主
去開箱去玩這一款遊戲
但是其實不用看他們怎麼樣玩
不用看他們怎麼評論
我就已經知道說這款遊戲中了
最感動的是看到Eligis
他在最後面的差不多15分鐘左右
他把遊戲打破之後
就是NG Plus破關之後
解出了真結局
然後他在那邊感嘆說
這真是一款超讚的遊戲
他相信這個遊戲會獲得一些
一定會再繼續重
然後他覺得很美麗
做得很好的遊戲
其實跟我的想法是完全一樣
雖然那時候我根本還沒有打破
因為這個遊戲的難度偏高
就是真的是需要稍微花一點時間
如果說你不擅長玩SoulLike遊戲的朋友們
所謂SoulLike就是說魂系
簡單講就是說他刻意把難度做到很高
你可以玩劇情模式
他裡面可以去設定你的傷害倍率
你就調大一點就變成說
那一刀可能就可以把王打殘這樣
這樣子可能就會讓你的遊戲體驗變得好
但學校多數的玩家
我相信跟我一樣
如果是喜歡SoulLike的話
我們是喜歡那一種
就是你一次又一次
義無反顧的把自己往王的臉上丟
然後一直被他殺掉
死了幾十次 100次 200次
然後接著把遊戲通關當你通關之後如果說你把這個直播影片放到網路上大家就會說你熟悉的令人心疼因為你每一個招式怎麼樣去做閃躲怎麼樣去做counter
你都是經歷過無數次的死亡才可以打過去
所以Soullike遊戲
甚至有點像是我們自己人生的寫照
以前我玩Soullike遊戲
怎麼講我最早其實不是他的粉絲
我是後來玩的就是艾亞登法環之後
才正式的變成Soullike的粉絲
也就是魂系遊戲的粉絲
然後我就一路去找這樣子的遊戲來玩
有些人說是自虐
但是如果說你懂得故中的奧妙的話
其實你會非常喜歡這種
就是你在把遊戲玩完之後
你不只是體驗一個遊戲
有些人會覺得說
遊戲玩完好像什麼就沒了
但你真的就學會一些東西
你再一次回去打那些網隊來說
其實都是很輕鬆的
你的神經好像都接好了之類的
所以你真的會學習到一些東西
那看著自己跟我們相產資本
去投資的非常優秀的貝果遊戲
所做出來的遊戲最後的呈現
不管是他的畫面 音樂
或是在每個非常intense的Boss Rush的戰鬥之中
大家回到修道院
坐在爐火旁邊喝個湯
配上很抒情很抒壓的配樂
然後跟一些可愛的NPC
以及最後面你發現
Ruby是可以換顏色的
達到NG Plus之後
就會覺得這個遊戲有非常多的深度
它是用一個像素風呈現
當然像素風有些人喜歡
有些人不喜歡
但我自己是非常喜歡
在像素風的這樣的一個有點懷舊
有一點舒服的氛圍之下
同時又帶有了非常Hardcore的打王的要素
然後跟我覺得它劇情的
深度跟感染力也非常的強大
同時因為我們去打一些遊戲的時候
其實有時候我們自己心中
會希望某一種劇情發生
現在蠻多遊戲他們喜歡去做一個
就是讓你非常難過
非常難受的一種體驗
他把它稱為是某一種
殘破跟殘缺的一種美麗或什麼的
可是我不知道在這個時間點
我可能需要的比較多是那種心靈上的治療
所以有一些劇情走向
剛好又切到了我內心中需要的東西
所以你還會打一打
不要心打到哭你知道嗎
傻小就是打遊戲打到哭
太感動了這到底是什麼東西
所以非常感謝Vagol遊戲
做出這麼棒的一個作品
也非常感謝Gameworks輔導他們
然後以及讓香蘭資本可以去參與他們
在他們需要幫助的時候
我們去挺一把
然後最後面這款遊戲順利的上市
並且在我心中
他已經獲得一個
就是至高無上的成就
就是不管最後面評價是怎麼樣
不管最後面賣了幾套Steam的同時上千人數是多少或者是最後面在Twitch上面是有多少人去觀看他已經無法改變的我覺得他是我人生非常重要的一個里程碑
我非常榮幸
我有這樣的機會可以來參與
我也非常感謝過去的自己
非常認真的工作
所以當然需要掏錢去做創投
這種大家都感覺說你瘋了嗎
你幹嘛不要去買一間房子
你幹嘛不要幹嘛
但我們就義無反顧的走下去
我非常感謝做出這樣決定的自己
當然最終非常謝謝
也歡迎露比這麼棒的一款遊戲
我有帶來一個極好的週末
在外面現在是有一點那種心風邪雨
你做什麼都不對
現在的環境就是你做什麼都不對
你整天就是要落賽
想說到底是小小
你努力了半天一點收穫都沒有
但最後面在遊戲裡面
本來以為說玩這種
soul-like的遊戲會虐待自己
但我發現一下外面的世界比這個遊戲更難
遊戲我們義無反顧的把自己丟進去
最後面就是會把它破關
但是外面的世界不一定
但我們希望外面的時間
最後面也是這樣
最後面也非常感謝所有支持
歡迎露比的各路的聽眾
地方捏軟
各路豪傑還有地方媽媽們
很多買給老公玩
這裡有一個小提醒
希望大家去寫評價的時候
盡量不要寫什麼夢宮愛寧或什麼的
因為太粉絲相關的東西了
我自己也是不喜歡
然後再來就是
你知道那種遊戲的粉絲
很多是很Hardcore
他們看到他們可能也不喜歡
所以希望大家不要雷我
希望大家就是專心的
去寫遊戲的評價就好
我下去看到遊戲的評價
其實絕大多數現在已經拉回正了
一開始我一看媽怎麼全部都是在講說
怎麼愛您撒小的
還好我去跟團隊
然後跟Gameworks聊這件事情的時候
他們說沒關係很溫馨
很像那種可能不知道
就是國高中同學會之類的
但最後面就是有回歸正軌
所以希望大家就專心在遊戲的評論
我們一定會再繼續的端出
更多的好作品給大家
那也希望大家喜歡紅顏露比
然後跟喜歡蕭南紙本
後面要推出的遊戲
或者不一定是蕭南紙本
但是是台灣人做出來的遊戲
希望大家都可以持續的支持下去
在這邊先跟大家說
感恩啦
安置謝
多謝利
Thank you very much
謝謝
希望大家都有美好的週末
希望下個禮拜市場就會轉好
一切都會往更好的方向
大概這樣
接下來我們來進入市場的話題
那目前的市場真的也蠻像魂系遊戲的
而且不是一般魂系遊戲的什麼開始的場景之類
是已經走到艾布雷菲爾
就是米凱拉的勝訴那邊
那個城鎮真的就是給你一種萬念俱灰
全部人都在等米凱拉回來
但是米凱拉沒有回來
我們現實之中的米凱拉是誰
我不知道我感覺是川普
就是感覺川普應該是要講一點話
突然說我們不想要打伊朗了
或什麼的
雖然我自己覺得
加的下跌跟伊朗沒有太大的關係
但就是需要一些那種catalyst
一些催化劑跑出來
可能是不知道Fed突然間決定
我們沒有要收攏
在大家預期可能開始拉高之後
告訴你說休息一下沒事
其實我們覺得AI
真的是像那些科技巨頭老闆講的
他是某個程度的通縮力量
所以不會有通膨
雖然我們在工業鏈上看
每個東西都在漲價
但如果他可以這樣講的話
說不定市場會扭轉
或者是說川普出來講一點話
市場就會扭轉
但我們之前有跟大家講說
其實川普現在出來講話的機率偏低
因為如果你今天是看Standard & Poor
就是標普500的話
它本身就是還在高位
所以它是裡面的一些成分股摔得比較重
當然台灣人覺得摔得很重的一個主因
或者說韓國人或者說日本人
是因為我們的股票裡面有蠻多都是那些AI components
或是AI相關的東西
在美國這邊你也是注意到說SOX
就是說廢城半導體指數
大概也是摔掉了快到三成
到最低點的時候差不多是這樣
所以當指數摔掉三成的話
大家是一定不會好受的
像跪買是直接得要爆掉
所以像我自己最近
也是有那種有感的感受到部位被引爆
就算你可能有躲進去盛虧股一點或什麼的
但無法改變的就是你每天都一直在輸錢
就是每天都在輸錢
稍微的找到一些新的題材
像我可能在本週就是有看到說
AMD有一個Avancing AI
我就往AMD的一些相關概念股去壓
他們是帶來一些震爆醜明說
但是它沒有辦法帶來的是
像你美國的部位
或是你台股的其他部位
所帶來的一些負報酬
所以就大概已經是往兩成多去跑了
再繼續往下跑
如果跑到什麼兩成五三成的話
我可能會再做更激進的保守的做法
因為其實真的不知道
現在到底發生什麼事情
所以現在的行情
越來越讓我感覺到很像去年的三月
可能我們在過去的節目
一直在講這樣的感受
我覺得現在越來越像
就是你不知道在跌什麼
就是認真說你在市場上
像我們去找一些那種買方的朋友
然後或是一些可能在海外大券商的朋友
大家都在討論到底發生什麼事
其實大家都眾說紛紜的
就是你沒有辦法明確的找到
有某個理由去導致這樣的一個現象
前面可能如果說你要用產業面的角度來說
可能是像是K3KIMI這樣的一個東西
對市場造成一些影響
可是後來KIMI這個事件在市場上
其實算是已經被大家消化完了
在我們上一集有跟大家聊到說
其實最終大家發現說它的用量只會更大
所以大家找不太到
是有什麼樣的一個直接理由去解釋這一波下跌就是有可能畢竟其實我們四五月的節目老實講講話都開始昂瞎了都開始說每天不知道要幹嘛都在處置股都一直在漲已經漲到就是什麼運動員
變成是我的本業
我整天都去運動
結果回想那段時間我發現說
那時候可能真的是過得太爽
所以現在就是那一種
你的獲利該被回吐了
就是該被懲罰的一個時間點
所以目前還是會先暫時
把它想像成為是
某一種估值的修正
只是這次的估值修正是非常變態的
因為其實有蠻多東西
特別是我們沒有辦法去點名一些標的
應該可能比較中小
但是我們自己有在注意的某一些設備股
它跌到10倍股以下
它甚至跌到7-8倍股
就是如果你用明年的EPS算的話
罵的超低
台灣的一些板材PCB相關的東西
跌到超低
那種10倍左右
想說這到底是什麼東西
為什麼他們的估值可以跌到這麼便宜
當然像這樣的事情過去也發生過幾次
有幾次應該說絕大多數證明
市場在瘋狂在亂殺
後面就回去
可是也有幾次是怎麼樣
就是它是走在前面
市場先跌
所以其實我們家都是非常擔心說
會不會是有些市場不知道的東西
現在正在作動著
類似像是去年的3月
一開始在跌的時候
大家都不知道跌什麼
然後後來反彈之後
川普拿出小板板
崩殺
那當然就跌完了
真的下去就跌完了
所以現在有點像是說
可能等到消息開出來就跌完了
只是等到消息開出來
你不知道要多久
你不知道還會繼續殘虐
大家都知道什麼時候
像在禮拜五的晚上的時候
台子又破底了
NQ也是破底
本來破底之後有拉回來
我想說This is it
No lower就這裡
但尾盤又再下去
所以老實講不知道
會不會下個拜要trigger一個新的賣壓出來
真的他媽太難說了
所以現在形態真的變得蠻難看的
我自己在心中的期待是應該要快點拉上去
如果拉不上去的話
隨著自己的進值的draw down越來越高
我預計大概可能到2成5 3成
其實一般可能不會到這麼深
才去再改新的策略
只是因為今年還OK
所以就會覺得再多吃一點
我可能也受不了
我就要再去修正一下
可能就開始要拉現金出來之類的
過去一陣子是在各種部位之間調來調去
可是有點發現說
好像也沒有什麼意義
多調多錯
包含說從台積電的財報開出來
他的財報其實是非常好的
然後崩掉
再來Google的財報開出來
Google的財報我們怎麼去評論
我們覺得是非常好
而且已經證明說
AI就是可以賺錢的東西
很多人就講說他現金有轉付
可是現金有轉付
其實如果聽我們節目知道
幾個月前我們就跟大家說
會有這個事情
因為市場充分預期
也不是只有我們的專利
大家都知道說你現金就在轉付
其實轉付這件事情對我們來講並不是一個特別了不起的事為什麼因為以前賣軟體叫做一本萬利我只要做出一個軟體我可以無限的copy基本上就是沒有什麼cost of goods我沒有多少成本
我就是一本嘛
所以可以萬利
可是現在不是這樣子
因為現在我們知道說
你所有的AI的軟體
或者說在軟體上面去賦能AI的
新的應用方面
它後面都是必須要有模型去跑
這些模型它本身就會是一種成本
所以你為了要去跑更多的AI
除了你要去做很多的先期投資
讓你的訓練的能量
或者說你的推論的能量放大之外
之後的每次運算
理論上你都會有一個新的成本在
所以這就是一個新的時代的變遷
這個有時候也讓我想到一件事情
因為其實像馬斯克
或是一些矽谷圈的人士會講說
外來的世界可能就是那種abundant
就是什麼東西都有一大堆
什麼東西都是無限的給大家取用
但是我覺得AI其實告訴了我們一個故事
就是什麼東西都還是有成本
不然像你要拿出很好的AI推論的結果
像我們之前有一集的開頭跟大家聊到
你的AI如果是用那種便宜的AI
很多時候它真的會錯很大
可是如果你用稍微貴一點的AI
我就再說我請AI去整理
AMD Events in Day的一個筆記給我
用Fable 5去跑
那一個
就如果說你讓我自己用工人智慧
自己上網去點
到底Lisa素是講了什麼東西
我覺得我大概10分鐘可以把它弄出來
我就知道他大概講了什麼
甚至直接去找一個逐字稿
然後快速有把它看過
這個對我來講
可能也不是一個太難的事情
就大概我猜可能20到30分鐘內
我就可以知道
這次他到底講什麼東西
但是我讓我的FableFi去跑的話
就是一個400塊的成本
跑下來他那個Token費就是400塊
所以其實我覺得
就是在後面的一些應用上
大家會開始拉回來一點點
過去是TokenMaxim
後來發現說
TokenMaxim除非說你本身
你終端產出的價值極高
如果說你終端產出的價值
你報給客人的價格
沒有辦法去有效的拉高的話
你AI越好
其實你的成本就越高
你的利潤會吃掉的越大
所以不如你乾脆去找一個公讀生
像上次跟大家分享
我去聽一些電話回憶
我不如去找一個公讀生幫我聽
那一定是比AI便宜
類似這樣子
所以可能等到未來
AI又再變得更強大的時候
我們還是相信說
你知道像科技業的發展
就是每一代的東西
當然它的售價有可能是持平的
但是其實你買到的CP值是越來越高的
就像是半導體的摩爾定律一樣
這個東西越來越萎縮越來越小
成本算起來是越來越低
給你的效能是越來越大
有照一律就相信AI就會變很便宜
只是現在就可能在某一種過度的階段
特別是外面我們講的供應鏈通膨然後從記憶體到被動元件然後再到功率元件載板各種什麼波線部Q部什麼PTFE殺小你所有可以想得到的東西
價格都是高張的
在這樣的環境之下
你其實真的是蠻難把成本壓下去
所以它可能會有點類似
我現在如果去硬要講的話
它會像是
那時候.com 拔木
我們建置了很多光線
一樣的道理就是
現在我們建置了很多AI
後來一定會有一段那種冷卻期
就是我們上集開頭講的
未來一定會有一個那種
諸神的黃昏
一定會有一個Armageddon會發生
就是現在的各種修正
其實跟你真的循環走完的比
那真的都沒得比
所以希望到時候大家都還活著
但總之應該是在那一波之後
然後AI就真的會變成是一個
超級便宜的東西
那就不會有像我們家的討論
就是說有些東西其實在使用上
我發現我用AI的話
可能其實是更貴的
那希望這個事情後來會有效的去改善
但是總之拉回來
就是我們剛剛講到說
我們認為Google這樣的一個投資
其實是非常合理的
因為如果你現在不投資
基本上你就是輸了
當然有些人可能會舉Apple作為一個例子
但是Apple我們之前也跟大家講過
當然它去槓桿別人是很聰明沒錯
但就是它一個路線選擇
可是如果你沒有夠多的
終端裝置的這樣的話語權
像蘋果基本上它是一個信仰的股票
大家iPhone就是死都會換
即便那個價格可能跟其他的手機
比起來貴很多都會換
它就是因為有這樣的一個信仰的力量去支撐它
所以它可能不用去大刀闊斧
去從事可能太多模型的開發
或是AI的一個資本投入
它是一個那種得天獨厚的位置
可是如果像以Google這樣的角度來講
它本身就是一個Cloud Service Provider
它就是一個CSP
所以它是一定要花錢的
所以像有些人下去
未付薪辭強說仇說它跌是因為現金流轉付
我就會想要反駁
因為第一個就是
早就知道現金流會轉付
然後第二個就是
它如果不轉付
它如果不去做這些投資
它後面會輸
所以其實現在去做越大投資了
其實在後面越有可能是贏家
這時候我就要quote
我們一位聽眾在臉書的回覆
他回覆的真好
他就說
他玩大富翁4的時候
還是哪一代
每次一開始買房子買到外破產的
最後面都會贏
然後光是收過路費就收到爆炸
所以其實我覺得真的就是這樣的一個
背景思維
你要有你就會知道說
OK所以你現在不投資的
反而是會稍微危險一點
除非你像蘋果那樣子
你掌握了一些通路跟中斷的用戶
不然其實你有可能會因為
你沒有去做投資就輸掉
所以接下來去看其他的
原因服務的巨頭
不管像是Amazon
然後不管像是Microsoft
或者說中國的BAT
我相信你都會看到類似的東西
這個錢是不得不花
然後在之後的每個Token的產出
其實都會是一個成本
所以一些利潤的數字
有可能就是會超出那種
可能沒有很研究的人的預期
他就覺得說奇怪了
你不是軟體股嗎
你不是在做軟體
不是software嗎
你不是應該很高
沒有因為現在你在背後
是必須要有運算的成本
在那邊去做消耗了
所以有可能是TAM更大
但是毛利數字被擠壓的一個結果
這個東西其實跟AI Server的
一個整體的構造很像
這大概兩三年前
我們在聊的時候就說
其實那些AI Server接很大的公司
除非說他今天是
去走一個可能是客戶只給他代工費
MVA的一個做法
那個料不用自己去做採購的話
那個毛利數字可以漂亮一點
可是如果他今天是
去走一個buy and sell的模式的話
他接越多AI伺服器
其實毛利數字會往下量
就是毛利率
可是他本身他會賺更多錢
因為他的單價是更高的
但是一個數學遊戲
但當時丟出來的時候
其實市場還是有些人會去講說
毛利掉下來要殺他
最後沒發現說就很無聊
那就是一個數字的變化
所以我還是相信說
就這些巨頭他們去做
這樣的投資是值得的
然後特別是在Google這次的數字
你可以知道說它的雲
就是獲得了一個
我認為算是巨大的成功
然後AI證實了就是可以賺錢的東西
只是為了去持續的獲得更多優勢
它必須要花更多錢
可是如果這時候你轉頭去看一下TESTA的話
TESTA也是花很多錢
但是TESTA花的錢
它的賽道就跟大家有點不太一樣
它是在評Physical AI這一塊了
所以會相對的難評價一點
我會認為說
如果你今天要我去幫股價講故事的話
我會覺得Google這個就是
我不知道你們在疊什麼
可是Tesla這個我可以理解
因為它有點像是說Meta那時候
要去做一些
主客人的時候會心想到某些東西
就要整個頭洗下去
市場一定會怕它
因為怕說你後面去做這個投資
會不會洗一本無歸之類的
但是如果說你是相信Physical AI
你是相信Optimus
機器人的未來的話
你也要去相信說
那他就一定要做投資
不做投資怎麼會有收穫的那一天
所以其實近期的各種數字
或是說財報
然後去導致的市場反應
我越來越看不懂的主因是
這邊都要強調一下
就是我們會去尊重股價的一個表現
可是我們心中一定會有一個定奪
這時候很多人會講說市場一定是對的
可是我們已經在過去多年的節目
讓大家知道說
沒有 市場其實蠻容易犯錯的
因為如果市場沒有犯錯的話
就不會有低谷掉下來給它撿
對不對
就是後面會上去的話
其實就代表說
當下可能某個程度上來說
你拉一個比較長的horizon
那是市場的犯錯
他們可能因為某些理由被嚇到
可能是恐慌
可能是一些流動性的擠壓或什麼的
導致會有一些崩跌的產生但還是得站在一個因為我們會比較以產業做一個聚焦的前提之下去看我們會去承認說有些東西我們看不懂然後我們去承受它的傷害
但是我們盡量還是把自己position在
這些我們知道說未來產業是不錯的
所以像另外一家公司
Texas Instrument
就是德州儀器TXN或是TI
它其實也是類似的道理
它在這次的電話會議
基本上釋出一個超級好的訊號
就是告訴大家說
它就是看到一個全面線的復甦
東西都上來
Data Center表現很好
他們開始漲價
這也是我們在幾個月前跟大家說
我們注意到公立元件
或者說類似半導體
他們其實最近都有一個漲價的情形發生
各家廠商都有
只是當然為什麼這個漲價
沒有辦法去驅動它的股價
或是為什麼市場會一直跌
老實講我們真的也不知道
但就是知道說
它在後面的產業發展
應該是持續的轉好
公司也是這樣跟大家說
所以現在的市場環境有點像是
你開壞的財報
你活該會跌
可是你開好的財報
市場也是要懲罰你 也是要跌
所以比較難去解釋為什麼
可是我們還是會見諒的
聚焦在產業的一個發展上
這邊稍微的跟大家更新一些
我們最近在產業上所獲得的資訊
先跟大家分享一個好消息
如果你後面是要去組電腦的話
從我們的角度看
在第4Q到明年的第1Q左右開始
其實我們已經注意到記憶體的價格會flat
聽到這邊不用太緊張
可能大家聽到記憶體的價格會flat
想說是不是漲價結束是不是要爆炸了
其實目前用我們的角度看
跟身邊的一些朋友討論之後
我們認為說可能是因為川普政府他們要記錄
因為前陣子已經有放出很多新聞
去講說韓國這些人毛利率
三星可能很快就要看到80
美光毛利也衝上去賺到翻掉
可能就會覺得說靠北
AI的發展是大家要一起
然後你們趁火打擊在那邊搶錢
當然有些人會幫他們說話
以前記憶體也很慘或什麼
可是現在是真的就是賺到爛掉
他們可能一年就賺好幾年的錢
所以應該是比較偏向
雖然現在講有點莫名其妙
良心發現
就是真的賺太大
像是魏哲嘉在自己台積電的場子
已經多次去講了
他也很羨慕他的客人
為什麼可以毛利這麼高
好像是要把客人掐死一樣
但現在應該是有一個
那種良心發現跟踩剎車
但這個可能已經是包含了
因為他在1Q跟2Q
那都是一個100%的一個增幅
然後到接下來的3Q
是開始去往收斂的方向
落在可能我們目前看
可能大概10到30%之間都有
去看各種不同的料號跟應用
接著到4Q就會收斂到
可能是10%以下
接下來應該就會是維持相對flat的一個狀態
如果說AI沒有什麼新的爆炸性應用逼大家立刻要再去上修更多capac投資的話應該就會維持在這個地方大家也應該有看到新聞去報說中國這邊開始拒絕漲價
什麼叫拒絕漲價
拒絕漲價人家還是不會賣你
因為不可以用搶的
他們的意思就是他們要轉去CXMT
他們要轉去中國國產
可是外面的世界
因為我們都知道說
目前CAPEX都還是持續在上修的一個trend
所以可能你未來有一天會看到
有報導開始寫出來說
那個記憶體flatten
然後市場會屌殺一頓
但這邊我們先講
我們認為那個是就是
大家發現說這個利潤拉到某個位置
在接下來可能跟客戶
或是跟美國政府都不好交代
所以可能提早去做一個修正
因為前面真的漲很多
但是應該還是有機會可以看到
記憶體相關的一些原廠
那個毛利會開到80去
那個真的非常的恐怖
其他的元件
我們都還是持續的注意到
在市場上都是漲價
所以如果我們今天是用
產業面的角度來看的話
真的就是可以直接講說
No change
並沒有太多的改變
市場只要新丟出什麼樣的議題
我們都會立刻在這邊去debunk
也不是說我們是那種超級死多頭
只是就是論事
像Kimi這個當時也是有一些那種
FUD的情緒跑出來
只是很快就被debunk掉
就是讓大家知道
其實它是意味著
就是它可能要用到的量是更大的
以及月之安面自己都講了
我的目前的算力是不夠用的
所以目前我們從基本面角度看
應該還好
但有可能就是有一些我們不知道的事情
這個可能在我們節目的週期裡面
或是大家的生涯裡面
就遇過很多次
最近一次就是去年的三月
就一開始你都不知道在跌什麼
然後最後面
你終於知道在跌什麼的時候
就啪啪啪 然後就跌完了
就結束了
所以要有一個心理準備要面對
後面可能會發生這樣的事情
所以為什麼就是說
可能在每次的大跌
你不應該去開太大的槓桿去搶
當然一定有些人會開槓桿去搶
然後搶到之後就跟你講說
你看這個地方本來就是要開槓桿什麼
但我們不喜歡把自己放在險境裡面
有時候可能慢一點
也是一種做法
你至少可以活得久一點
所以目前會比較尊重就是說
我們可能有一些未知的東西
在市場上正在醞釀中
不然好難去解釋為什麼會這樣
有可能就單純的去修估值
修到某個地方
目前我們看產業可能都還是OK的
直下比較險惡的就是說
指數這邊開始又出現一些破底的出現
如果說破底持續
然後或是開始加速的話
可能就要比較小心一點
當然每個人有不同的方式
去Hedge掉這樣的風險
有些人可能是使用
他拿多一點現金
有些人可能會去放空單
像我自己這一波的話
我覺得應該就會是去騰現金我目前還沒有去騰我就是在個股之間切來切去然後後來發現說有時候以為自己是蘇馬克像禮拜五的早盤在台股看到說靠北那個賣壓感覺已經賣不太下去了
左邊的買盤
一些那種主流的股票
感覺已經沒有人要接了
可是同時一直賣又砸不下去
然後做多之後
果然早盤就拉起來
拉起來之後我就想說穩了
這邊應該就是了
結果後來尾盤再殺下去
所以現在盤很難搞的點
就是它一直有這樣的狀況產生
然後讓你好像救了一點績效
可是你又再被套到更多東西
然後接著你可能又因為說
有些東西已經打到你的停損或是停利點
你就只好要再把它清掉
可是當你把它清掉
你換去新的東西
你可能又再次的受到傷害
不管你去挑
可能是你現在感覺很強勢的東西
想說至少只有共識
你會被打之外
然後再來就是
你想說那跌生的東西
跌無可跌吧
幹 還是會被打
因為它還是會距離跌
所以真的是比較難處理
如果說發現自己不太會做
看不懂的話
其實最好的一個保命的方式就是
維持靈感感
可能有點現金
然後再來就是降低交易的頻率
等到什麼時候
就等到說一些形態轉好
開始站回去一些主要的均線
當然希望他扣底比較是負的
這樣狀況之下
可能就是會稍微的好一點
所以我個人是希望在下禮拜
應該要看到有反彈的
如果說還是沒有看到的話
應該就是有可能
真的市場上有醞釀一些事情
我們持續的再去做觀察
以上
所以目前的遊戲體驗
真的很像那種魂系的感覺
多做多錯
然後有很多的懲罰
如果你要去跑回
你有魂點去撿錢的話
可能又會再遭受更多的傷害
最後一毛都撿不回來
真的有點像在這樣的一個感受
希望在接下來的回檔
大家可以好好地守住下檔
因為今年其實在7月以前
真的是一個非常好
好到很誇張的一年
希望大家都可以至少守住一些戰果
就不要說什麼到最後是空手而回
甚至是開始賠錢
那可能就是一個比較不好的狀態
大概就這樣
接下來我們進去的部分
第一位還在想ID
夢光安安紅顏綠比太好玩了
讓我暫時忘記最近的大回檔
但還是想問
成熟制成怎麼了
真的是因為未懂喊下去了嗎
相信主委解惑愛您
其實如果說各位是真的會看盤
其實看盤不是一個多難的事情
就是把各個族群都拉出來看的話
瞎你就會發現這種問題
連問都不用問
你乾脆你跟我講什麼沒跌
你乾脆跟我說什麼沒跌
就只有那種什麼
忠實化殺小那些
數化類股在漲
除了那些東西之外
可能腳踏車相對穩一點
但那根本就沒有辦法放大錢
就是所有科技股都在跌
所以一般在這種時間點
我覺得不用太刻意的去找理由說
它到底在跌殺小
除非說它跌到比Benchmark多很多
以目前的科技股
像我們剛剛前面講說
它最低就是撞了三成
所以嚴格上來說
你只要是犯科技類股
你可能在三成
都是在大盤的範圍內
其實它不一定算是跌很多
像你家講的成熟製程
我不知道一直在講哪一家
但是其實他們最近也回蠻深
但是你說特別深
沒有因為其實每個東西都掉下去
你說各種元件
或者說甚至那種Power相關
光通相關
光通一堆跌到五成去
所以其實就是大家都跌
現在狀況之下
你不用再去問說到底怎麼了
沒有怎麼了
就是市場在做大屠殺大概這樣
下面一位 Eric Wong
猛公你好你知道吃水餃要去哪裡領嗎
當鋪因為Dompling
好啦好啦那什麼動物會紋內褲呢
因為豹紋內褲
想請教孟公記得你某一集說過大家都有黃金廚具
那Parentier做的算是黃金料理嗎
那首先笑話部分的話
Dompling那個應該5.3吧
然後再來豹紋內褲的話2分
蠻爛的
那他算不算黃金料理
我覺得算耶
就是Pan Tier的應用
你可以很明確在市場上就知道說
它沒有太多的禁品
它可以去接到這些什麼國防部的案子
或什麼的
那個都是屬於非常那種Niche Market
很特別的應用
你可以要過很多的法尊
然後或者說有很多的驗證或什麼的
這種生意就是基本上只有它可以做
目前是這樣子
所以你從這邊就知道說
這個東西它就是
某個程度的黃金料理
它就是說有沒有辦法去justify它的估值
有沒有辦法去支撐它的成數
這個不一定
可是你說他產品好不好
那個肯定是好的
下面一位
Welson
HiHiChibichka
括號已經不是了
我是阿正還記得我嗎
把節目當佛經聽的26歲好愛保
括號0.0038的聽眾
我有自己的CD
已經1.6倍速乘以3
循環播放完畢
助於觀念的累積
分析不懂沒關係
夢工今生得我心
上次留言經過半年
畢業後在實驗室當研究員外
也嘗試著其他多元的收入
下次留言可以塞個小廣告
祝夢工一家
身體健康最重要放前面
股票噴噴噴噴被釘在牆上後挖得下來
Choco不用幹你娘
PS紅眼露比登上日本排行啦
期待攻上世界各地排行愛您
我們旗下的作品最近跟日本都蠻有緣的
非常感謝這些日本朋友們的支持
當然我相信有些可能是在日台灣人
說不定他那個Steam也被劃在日本去
但希望我們可以持續在全球都拿下很棒的成績
希望你一些順利
下面一位困擾
想到以後可能沒有鼓癌可以聽
還是有點感傷
感覺很像高中畢業
要跟一起打屁的损友各奔东西一样有没有考虑开一个新的节目不用固定更新想录的时候再錄就好掛號小石頭拍拍分享生活聊聊心心去讓大家偶爾線上GG就很棒了愛您這集封面可以用這紙嗎
放一個恐龍
其實這個我真的有考慮
因為其實首先第一個就是說
我的節目我話也跟大家坦誠
我最喜歡的是開頭跟QA
其實我甚至是有點反感股票宅
就讓我前陣子跟大家聊到
你知道前陣子就是有蠻多人
都會一直去催我
到哪都什麼古來說古來說
我不是說我最討厭這種
就是什麼都我說我說的
因為你看後面就會嘗到一些苦果
修正之後
因為你看人家在社群上大量的去貼
所以大家就會說
那個骨骸不是說什麼
我就想說
你們這些在罵吃二手小的
就是你們也沒有真正來聽節目
你們就是可能在社群裡面
大家在那邊自嗨在那邊FOMO
然後最後面可能發生一些事情
然後又要開始去抓戰犯
其實我覺得現在跟2021 2022比好很多
因為我發現投資人在蠻理性的
但有時候看到你還是會很不悅
因為其實你就是好好在講你的東西
你也不會因為行情的變化
你知道像我們節目
我們不會因為說什麼東西跌
我們就說一個東西是垃圾
我們不看跌說跌
我們也不會看漲說漲
可是我們沒有辦法控制市場的循環
有時候就是因為這樣會被煩到
所以其實我對一些市場仔
我自己是蠻不喜歡的
或許對我自己是有在想
就是在可能真的要大爆炸之前
就是要退休
因為我就不想再去承受一些
莫名其妙人的想法
或是可能就直接把這個節目
就完全轉型成為
我覺得我自己可以接受的方向
應該是就純QA
我們就是聊天
當然在聊天之中
你想要去問我一些我自己工作的東西
不管是股票
或者說我的孩子育兒
或者是我的遊戲投資
餐廳 甜點店
或者什麼有的沒有的投資
或甚至我自己有在想
搞不好明後年說不定也會弄個
就是功能性訓練真的蠻好的
如果真的有教練要做的話
我也想去支持他們之類的
就是你要去聊這些東西是可以
可是我已經對於這種市場的東西
越來越興致缺缺了
特別是每次的循環之後
其實就是又會再稍微的懂一點東西
覺得像2021 2022那段時間
就是讓我後來我比較少在
甚至是自己的Telegram去做發言
因為我就發現說奇怪了
下跌的時候大家都是一起不好受
我還要去額外承擔一些那種快樂寶貝的心情
就是怎樣
上去的時候沒有半句謝謝
下來我又要承擔
就會覺得這種東西做久會心累
所以不確定
但我自己也不是那種會戀戰的人
所以可能就到時候再看
可能要嘛就是節目
可能會稍微轉一點形式
或是其實節目會維持
只是我心理素質就變得更強大
我會知道說其實我要忽略所有的雜音
我認為我該講的東西就好
我不應該去管別人怎麼想之類的我不曉得啦只是我那時候會這樣講的原因是因為因為我們不是在什麼下跌可能之後才跟大家講說我累了不要做了
是我在前面還在狂漲那段就講
所以這其實跟股票行情沒有太大關係
就是因為你一個東西你做久
你一定會覺得有一點膩
或者說可能比較沒有那種新鮮感之類的
或許後面會找到新的方向
不一定
大家不會去想這個啦
因為我們生活中其實太多東西要做了
我自己目前還是很感謝
有一個節目可以跟大家分享
發生了什麼事情
然後有一些那種共鳴會產生
當然他一定會有一個程度的
怎麼講就是預帶王冠必成其重
不是說這是王冠
意思就是說每個事情
就一定會有他的正反兩面之類的
所以可能是我自己也要去學習
大概這樣
下面一位 包皮好癢
早晨射在臉上的不一定是陽光
夢宮看完奧德賽了嗎
記得很久以前你有講過
你是諾蘭粉
想聽聽你的心得
然後最近要開始面試地獄了
求觀音導來保佑我面試順利
成功上岸的話
將捐半個月的薪水給台大醫院
有他Apple Podcast的留言似乎修好了
有打算換回原本的留言模式嗎
其實可以考慮
只是我們也在Spotify
我是覺得這個模式還蠻不錯的
然後Spotify
以前我不太喜歡的是
Spotify上面的股票仔超多
但現在Spotify我覺得也蠻正常的
所以我們盡量還是維持一樣的邏輯
就是一個東西如果說沒有壞掉
我們就不要去修它
就先維持Spotify
然後之後可能發現說
Spotify的那種怪咖又開始變多之類的
我們再換一個模式
也不一定是換回Apple
說不定我有在想
因為搞不好有些人根本他可能這兩個平台都不好接觸
還是說用寫信之類也可以
但寫信我就比較難去閱讀
所以這個後面有狀況
我們再來去做思考再看怎麼辦
然後再來奧德賽看了沒
還沒看
而且我聽說奧德賽幹超扯
他那個票是他有黃牛票
我朋友跟我講說我媽傻掉
因為電影票理論上是取之不盡用之不竭的
就是他不像一些可能演唱會或一些表演
他就只有一兩場
所以你知道有些人想要在那邊耍尾戲
你還算可以懂為什麼有人會這樣做
媽的電影票
電影票你不就是
你這個禮拜看不到
你就看下個禮拜就好了
就你一定會看得到
所以我只能夠說就蠻瘋狂的
本來你可能在網路上看到很多吐槽
還以為說什麼
蠻多人會不去看之類的
最後發現說網路的聲量
跟限制之中的銷量
那還是有一定程度的落差
總之我應該會去看這一部電影
如果之後發現
有什麼有趣的東西
再來跟大家分享
下面一位新手上路
哈囉愛大好
我男友自出社會以來
一直都是你的忠實聽眾
長期佈局台美股的ETF
甚至投到銀行帳戶沒有剩多少現金連便當錢都要巧的地步當時的我經常覺得無言但这两年也累积出一笔资产可以支持我们往人生的下一个阶段迈进非常感谢埃大的分享
最后希望埃大可以用川普的声音
祝喜欢半夜看美股的巨蝎座
莱恩
Wow what a great guy
Wonderful guy
Tremendous guy
Lizzy's happy birthday
Rion
也非常恭喜你们
经由长期的投资累积
现在有一些收获
希望可以持续下去
下面一位宅客瑞王
孟公 你好
之前听您说
如果有坐在会议室前面试的机会
就是一种肯定
让最近在求职的我更有勇气跟信心
前阵子去面试了一家公司
虽然有些问题没有回答的很好
但是感觉是近期以来最不紧张的一次面试
那这边希望可以顺便跟观音许愿
如果说上了愿意捐三个月20%的薪水出去
那另外可以麻烦孟公祝我顺利取得offer
妈爱您也祝您全家
平安健康秋狗继续干你娘
希望这位兄弟可以顺利的面试过关
小米卫 迪化街的台南人
MK大家可以多分享一些红颜路比团队的故事吗
像团队的组成缘由跟怎么样想出游戏的内容
好游戏的故事值得分享
我发现随着年纪增长
对事物的激情跟热情会慢慢的降低
就连我很爱的游戏跟科技投资也是
年纪长大像秋口叫你也不会再骂他了
后来就慢慢的转向大盘
游戏时间也大减
年輕時聽長輩說羨慕年輕人的熱情
覺得是幹話
現在他的體感是真心話
後面講的那段我覺得非常的有感覺
但如果今天讓你回到你年輕的身體
除非說你帶著充滿歷練的各種心境去體會
不然其實你就仔細回想
其實當年你去看這些東西的時候
你也不會去想太多
你可能會覺得說反正我一定可以一直再來
然後等到有一天你就發現
其實你的人生就是在倒數
大家會想說我今天輸多少錢
淨值回多少
可是你有沒有想過說
你每少一天你就
也不要講輸掉一天
就一天就沒了
它跟少掉的淨值不一樣
少掉的淨值可以配回來
可是少掉的一天是回不來的
但是當你可以意識到這件事情之後
你就會對生活之中的一些小事
可能開始會多放一點心思
會多注意
但你如果去跟年輕人講
你叫他說你還有很好的身體
或是熱情的時候
你多做一些
他可能懶得屌
你又想說老子都沒錢了
我家連生活都有煩惱
我下一餐在哪
我都不太確定
房子買不起怎麼小的
你跟我講這些我怎麼會懂
所以只能夠說
這個就是人生可能很矛盾
很諷刺的一點吧
你年輕的時候
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕